the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and again I want to say
thank you since I've been back the
outpouring of love has been so
overwhelming we're gonna do an episode
very soon my specials dropping very soon
as well so keep an eye out for that make
sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
and if you gotta have more you I'm
telling you you just go check out the
patreon it's five bucks a month if you
sign up for a year you get over a month
free you get the Honeydew a day early
you get it ad free at no additional cost
and it's the Honeydew with you all it's
your stories it's the I'm telling you
every week I'm like what are we gonna
hear this time and every week I leave
being like what the [__] that we just
here you guys have the absolute wildest
story so go check that out
um and if you're looking for a new
podcast check out my old podcast it's
called The Crab Feast it's a
storytelling podcast it's Audio Only
there's a seven year Library there go
download it have fun with it all right
now that's the biz you guys know what we
do over here we highlight the low lights
I always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers and I can't tell
you how excited I am today to have this
guest here first time on the Honeydew
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
David Cross welcome to the Honeydew baby
cry thank you thanks for having me Ryan
thank you for being here you've been a
pleasure since you got here I watched
you parallel park and you [__] nailed
it I said dude that's impressive you
said New York man East Coast well I uh I
didn't know who was talking yeah
and like looking is that a laminate and
I got a you know rental car I don't even
know how and and remember I left it on I
started walking away
you know
what and there's uh it was a tight fit
it was good yeah that's uh that's Boston
that's the uh oh it's boss driving in
Boston yeah it gave me that taught me
that skill
um yeah and then there were like two
strangers who are like that was
impressive man all right what what okay
put this permit your car where the [__]
are you
um listen before we get into everything
we're gonna talk about please plug
promote everything you'd like uh sure
I've got I'm gonna be going back out on
the road uh on tour starting March 2nd
it's called the worst daddy in the world
tour and uh you can find uh all the
information where I'm going and where to
get tickets at my website which is
officialdavidcross.com we got 40 cities
on the first leg oh yeah
um there's more to come they're they're
all kind of coming in and then uh gonna
take a couple months off uh uh to visit
my daughter who I I understand
Mrs me or something and uh
and then
and then I'll go back out again and I'll
hit uh the rest of Canada and Europe and
the rest of the state so then the first
leg and where where can they get tickets
Michelle davidcross.com boom what's your
Instagram and all that stuff
uh
are you just at David Cross or the Dave
no uh the one on Twitter has three s's
it's David Cross with three S's and
Instagram I'm not sure I'm gonna guess
is probably official David crosstalk I
know I mean I post stuff on there so
people can know about it but I'm I I had
to get a new phone uh quite recently and
um and purposely didn't put Instagram
and Twitter on there because uh
Twitter's awful Instagram's fine but uh
Twitter's just terrible and uh and even
pre-elon musk yes what is the dumpster
fire for sure just all of them and uh
and you know I can't say my life is
better because I'm not on there but it
probably is if I I'm just you know for
mental health issues want to get out of
there and uh and it's also a waste of
time and you know
um and I I think about a lot more stuff
when I'm taking a [__] now
my world is opened up man listen uh you
you said you're 58 I'm about to be 50.
and before the internet I used to read
the the reason I know that there's
placenta in shampoo is because there was
nothing else to read in the bathroom I
was taking a [__] and I started reading
the back of shampoo and greens I was
like there's placenta who yeah why do
you think uh there are so many abortions
so many questions because of actually
that no they wouldn't you wouldn't have
a placenta you wouldn't come out I don't
know excuse my ignorance ladies uh
yeah you wouldn't if you're having an
abortion you wouldn't the placenta
wouldn't come with it would it I I don't
know I would imagine the placenta is not
formed yet because that's what protects
the baby so if you're doing it it's
probably not formed yet that's my guess
as an ignorant man no it's a good guess
it's a solid I feel like it's a solid
one ignorant guy backing up another
ignorant guy you know and that my
friends is the internet that's the
internet in a nutshell
[Music]
we should be
to be at a bar
no man no no listen listen listen listen
it just makes sense listen listen to me
what I'm saying yeah oh my God all right
so I do want to talk to you about being
a dad but before we do that I want to
get to know you so where are you where
are you originally from Boston no no no
tell me all about you uh the longer
story is I was born in Atlanta uh moved
uh when I was one to Florida lived in
three places in Florida
and then
two places in Connecticut and then three
places in New York uh every year moving
every year
um before I move back down to Georgia
when I was nine and then lived in
Atlanta or or kind of um Suburban but
when I was a kid it was very rural rural
suburban uh Georgia outside of Atlanta
uh
until I was 19 and then moved to Boston
for nine years got it and that was for
comedy
uh I mean I mean yes but ostensibly the
it was to go to college I went I took a
year off because I had no money but um
uh between high school and
and uh
College I went to Emerson College but I
dropped out immediately uh
um I just had no money I got I got had
enough money to go there part-time they
had they would did it by two semesters
and then a full time a semester and then
part-time and then I dropped out I just
ran out of money and my student loans
you know that was it and I had a Pell
grant for x amount of money Pell Grants
you know so why were you bouncing around
so much uh up to age nine what was going
on where you're moving to Connecticut in
three places in Florida and
um this is it sounds like a joke but
it's just it's true uh my dad just got
fired a lot
he got fired a lot
a lot boy did that guy get fired
my goodness he was the king of the park
and he was one of those
jobs do you remember why he got fired
um well I was a kid like he he's uh the
dudes of uh he's not a good guy and he's
a pathological liar in the sense that
um nothing and I mean nothing was ever
his fault so he was one of those classic
you know you can't fire me I quit like
well now we did we did fire you already
you're you're trying to quit
retroactively and that doesn't it
doesn't work that way sir you're like
I've I will not stand for this treatment
I quit no I'm you don't understand we
fired you over 72 hours ago
you can't he's still coming back so he
yeah he had a series of jobs he was a um
uh uh initially when I first met him uh
he was
he was a uh uh a Salesman for women's
swimwear and I remember the company are
you being for real yeah yeah for a
Salesman for women it was called coal of
California c-o-l-e coal of California
and
um I don't know what brought him uh
uh to
Georgia he met my mom he was in the Army
he he uh
he came over on the boat with his whole
family uh in in different stages I they
came from a larger family uh from Leeds
England and he was 15 when he came over
the youngest of five kids and aunts and
uncles and all that came over as well
and uh
um they all settled in the Bronx or Long
Island and uh and my dad grew up uh you
know he was in Leeds and then he was in
the Bronx and then he joined the army I
think to help speed up his citizenship
and uh met my mom in Ann Arbor uh where
she was teaching uh English
um and
uh
and then they I don't know the whole
story of their kind of you know
courtship it was fairly quick and um
and then I was a honeymoon baby and then
uh and I was I don't know why he
why this
English dude would be in Atlanta Georgia
in the 60s
um but
he was and uh I don't know what he was
doing then and then then we moved to
Florida and he was definitely doing this
uh women's swimwear and he was a
traveling salesman too for a while and
you know later on
you know we it it was uh and I'm I have
two younger sisters I'm I'm very close
with one of them
um and we just over the years started
doing kind of deductive detective type
work and realized
Justin like oh that explains this and
then like he was having Affairs all the
all over the place he he you know he was
again not a not a great guy and um
uh
and so from there he we were in Florida
in three different places and then when
I was I guess around five we probably
moved up to Connecticut
um because that's when I started going
to school
um
so I'd be like five six yeah
um and there were a couple days there
and then he was working for oh he he had
at some point he and this other guy
opened up a store
uh in Connecticut I remember this too
the Le balm Marche it was like the good
uh was Marche in French internet help me
out get back to us so I'll respond the
it's like the good you know Market or
something like that but it was this
store
and they sold uh
um you know it was a little place you
know um somewhere in Connecticut and uh
um
and they sold women's clothing but then
they had this uh uh contest right to to
entice people to come in you get a
certain thing then you you enter the
drawing and you get uh you could win a
vacation for two in uh the Bahamas and
uh
and the craziest coincidental thing
happened it's [__] bonkers the I
don't know what the odds are if you've
scientifically but he ended up winning
it's crazy how does that work how is it
possible
so he and uh
hey guess what I got I got a steel drum
out of it I got a mini steel drum that's
what I got there's one of those
downstairs in the music store
um
yeah congrats yeah
and then uh um and then we were in New
York and then he was working for uh wait
who did he take you take your mom yeah
him him and my mom and then the other
couple also went okay He didn't take
like um oh no no no no no no no no no no
no
he took he no that would that's pretty
that would be bad
um and then we ended up uh you know that
went out of business uh no way it did I
know I know even though he's not good I
know the bargains shutting places down
well no he fired himself it was really
uh
he fired himself then tried to quit and
then himself said you can't quit I fired
and then he uh he had a you know it
broke the time continuum and he oh my
God but
and then we were in New York for a while
uh we were living with my grandma
because they know he had no money and uh
so we were to live my grandma my
grandmother
uh no wait your mom's mom my mom's home
yeah uh uh really didn't care for him
and I didn't understand when I was
younger my grandmother was really like
one of the coldest like odd people uh
just no warmth at all and didn't
particularly
care for us and we were the byproduct of
this uh and you know she was also shitty
to my mom and um uh
and you know just judgmental and
ridiculing her and she didn't like my
dad from the get-go and she called I
mean she to her credit she kind of did
say this guy's bad news and my mom
who was very uh didn't have a whole lot
of experience wasn't very social uh you
know there's this guy I don't think she
had you know I think she had one
relationship before she met my dad one
like legit and um uh and like here's
this guy who and my dad my mom and dad
were completely different like my mom is
really smart book smart not very social
very intellectual
um
but again that doesn't have a lot of
friends never did uh and doesn't isn't
particularly interested in that and I
was just happy to read and stuff and uh
um and my dad not very bright street
smart he was Street Smart uh but not
intellectually smart but really social
and Life of the Party funny guy
um just two completely different people
uh and
you know my mom was uh you know fell in
love with this guy because finally
there's somebody and he's really popular
and people and he what I was I hung out
with my dad a bunch before you know we I
haven't seen him since I was 19. I
really cut him up yeah I was like this
he's he's not you know as I said he's a
piece of [__] but um it took me a while
to get over to to see it and to
and not just to see it but to lift the
veil you know and there's a point as a
kid too when you you think every adult
is smarter or whatever because they're
older and then there's a point when you
get old enough you're like oh you're a
dumb one of those yeah I'm smarter than
you and then you start to really look do
the math on your parents and you know
it's 19's I mean look I I had the same
situation but but then you go on to be
who you are he's does he Reach Out does
he try to contact you no uh part of the
um
and this is this this is I mean this
sincerely uh
um you know following the logic of our
uh uh conversation
he
really did pulled a you can't fire me I
quit kind of thing meaning he told
uh so I'll tell you exactly there's this
whole long story that that led up to
this
um but just it was the straw that broke
the camel's back
um you know nothing like shocking but
it's just accumulation of all this stuff
that's another one to go all right I'm
done man and um I already knew he was a
piece of [__] but uh
uh I had gotten back from Florida where
we were supposed to hang out it was this
long story but uh uh I got back
and he
called
uh and um I should also say my my mom
and dad uh separated like right after I
turned 10. uh so we were in Georgia for
maybe
I want to say five months you know uh I
I probably just turned 10 and then
um and then he
left to go to you know work his [__] out
and find you know and and when I say he
left he left a um
a mountain of debt and responsibilities
and and just left my mom and with three
kids zero money less than zero uh no
credit
um my mom didn't have any skills really
and uh we're in [__] Roswell Georgia
and uh
I mean just uh massively uh
self-centered uh you know
zero responsibility no money nothing and
um uh and he left to go work his [__]
out or whatever the [__] it is but he
left he didn't go like
he didn't go downtown he went to Phoenix
Arizona
sorry that's way too yeah it's um it's
not even I thought you were gonna say
Florida which is still a drive from
Atlanta he went to feet and now um Wendy
and I my sister and I haven't really
cracked this one but what brings
a dude who's never been to Phoenix
to Phoenix of all places to escape his
family and we still haven't figured it
out but there must have been something
for him to go to Phoenix seems like a
hot bikini Market though those women oh
he was out of that he was out of that
because he he was a he became a um
a chef at a country club
um he became uh and then he had
uh he was a maitre d at a restaurant
um in Florida
um
I don't know some of the other jobs he
had but uh
again he was really good at
you know nailing the interview as it
were and and you know like a lot of uh
uh he's the most um
trumpian guy like he literally nothing
is ever his fault cannot uh can't oh you
know take responsibility
that would be an interesting podcast to
have a guest like that every week and
say all right these are the things these
are why you were fired what's your side
I'll tell you my side and then just hear
them never take ownership but never
never the guy never took ownership I'm
telling you here he's so similar to
Trump in that way of like I'm you know
I'm the only guy I can
uh you know and just never says I'm
sorry never takes ownership nothing's
his fault and uh
so uh
so he called the the apartment
and my little sister is like you know
talking to him and it's like it's it's
Dad Dad wants to talk to you and I said
uh
some you know variation of uh no I'm not
talking to him anymore something like
that
and and she's there's a little silence
and she goes he says good because the
only time you ever talk to him is when
you ask him for money which is so
he's relaying this to your little sister
to tell you it's so but it's so the
opposite so it's the thing that
he thinks is gonna hurt me that did hurt
me but not in the way that he thought it
was gonna hurt me and because it's so
it's it's
so not true like I had reached out the
guy never he didn't he didn't
you know he when I when he abandoned the
family he abandoned the family and uh it
was only through kind of reaching out
that anything you know remained and
and the uh and the guy never had any
money anyway and uh
and uh you know deadbeat dad I actually
went
to court in Arizona I went to go live
with them when I was 13 I think some are
uh sixth grade what is sixth grade yeah
about that 13 14. and uh
um
that's its whole its own set of crazy
stories but uh
um
just you just to live with them yeah
yeah and uh uh
and
I had to go to court one day because
there was nothing to do with you know he
where was he gonna put me you know
there's nothing uh and that became its
own issue and uh
um
you know he you know made no plans for
for having a 13 year old boy there and
uh and didn't also didn't alter his uh
thing and uh
um
and uh and so like I there were a couple
times that I went to this bar uh and he
wasn't like an alcoholic or drug abuse
or anything but um
but he did like he did Scare up uh jobs
and and there were always this uh you
know oh Patsy owes me money you know
whatever and uh you know he's got to go
uh go to a bar and do some kind of deal
and he'd give me you know two dollars
and quarters to go play Pinball for an
hour you know that kind of thing and uh
um what's the point of all this uh oh
yeah so I went to I had to go to a court
date in uh Court what whatever the the
court is for family social you know
stuff and uh
and there's a big I remember those they
had those big kind of cement uh big
columns that they just painted white you
know it was like one of those kind of
um
places in this court big big courthouse
in Phoenix and um there's clipboards
hanging off them like rubber bands and
the clipboards with all kinds of you
know just lines and lines and lines and
there's your name and here you got to
sign in and your court date is you know
here's the time is it 2 10 p.m whatever
and we went into
um a little courtroom kind of you know
People's Court type thing but more
fluorescent light and you know not no
wood but uh sat there waited we watch
person after person go through those
little saloon doors yeah walk up you
know uh stand behind a table what's your
name you know Gary Revere and uh um you
know have you uh you know you're here
because you uh oh remittance to this
thing or uh to this person uh have you
uh paid remittance uh know your honor I
haven't uh and what is the reason I've
not found uh I've not found employment
or gainful employment I did this uh for
10 days but then I couldn't uh that was
the uh extended the job have you looked
yes I have uh okay thank you and then
and this is line of
guys
it didn't stop and it was quick it was
like it was just a machine all right
boom boom boom and then Barry cross my
dad goes up and uh
uh you know does the
you know 30 seconds of who are you
what's your number
um you uh uh Susan Susie cross is uh has
brought your name up
um
have you do you have the money no I do
not have you been able to send money no
I have not uh what's the reason I've not
found gainful employment uh what is what
is your record of trying to find gainful
employment uh I did this and this and
this and this thing and I'm sitting
there going like no he didn't
oh
there was that I mean I know he was
[__] the landlord's wife to get free
but I don't remember him going I mean we
went to that bar we went to the bar I
don't remember playing uh Fireball the
fireball pinball machine but I don't
remember I don't remember him maybe he
was trying to get you know whatever and
uh
and then we just are like okay thank and
then we we just walked out and
I was on the other side of that in in
Atlanta where we had no money and uh
um
and like now you're seeing why you're
not and it's like that's all that's all
that you just go up and you say these
things even if he wasn't lying or or
even uh uh exaggerating it's still just
it was very eye-opening like oh nobody
cares this is all you have to do it's
just a perfunctory thing you have to go
to the court on this you know on the
16th at 11 42 you go in there
uh they they ask you 10 questions you
answer them and then you leave and five
minutes later you're you're back home
not sending money to your kids you know
uh and just the barest I'm talking about
that my mom never asked for a penny more
than uh we didn't get anything but um
but anyway yeah so what happens at 19
for you to finally say all right that's
it well again it was cumulative it was
uh uh
also just becoming my own person
becoming independent and becoming uh
you know I think the the the that stuff
starts taking shape when you're a
teenager anyway
um and
and having uh you actually got to live
both sides of that equation too and
really see yeah well the hot dogs are
made yeah and um or not not that it
wouldn't it wouldn't have surprised me
um if somebody had said that but just
kind of being a part of that and also
there's a there's the
unspoken kind of
underlying part of it that was there
which is
he didn't even bother to like he didn't
care that he or he didn't not that he
didn't care he
it was such a part of his thing and part
of his world and this is just how it
works that didn't matter whether I was
there to go hey Dad I don't
when did you try to get a job and it
didn't matter it was that's the thing he
did and you go in and even if I had a
big argument with him he'd probably just
go well then go the [__] home then
go back to Atlanta you know
um without the swear words
um but you know he
that was just a weird part of it was
like that's that's okay it's just like
yeah you're you know but but there were
there were just so many
um so he ended up coming back to
so we we
I mean it was comical the where first we
were when I got out there we were in a
suburb of Scottsdale called Fountain
Hills we were at somebody's house
um somebody he made friends with and
told some sob story too again I don't
know what brought him to Phoenix in the
first place it's such a weird and and my
sister Wendy and I haven't just not
cracked that yet is he still alive yeah
he's he's uh live he's in New York
um he's been there since I moved there
in 2000 early 2001 spring of 2001 and
and he was there uh at one of the fans
just hit him with an anonymous email and
go hey hey Barry Oh I have no I have no
interest zero to Phoenix and uh uh
and he you know I I I've he's out of my
head really you know and uh but
occasionally
very rarely I very rarely find myself
on the Upper East Side but occasionally
I'll be riding my bike or whatever I'll
I'll have some work or something will
bring me to
because I know he's in like the upper
60s 70s on the east side somewhere like
like first or second Avenue or Third
Avenue something like that and uh and
I'll just have forgotten about his
existence and then as I get closer I'll
be like oh right Dad lives up here
somewhere you know but he's you know I'm
there are a couple of uh relatives his
nieces uh that are still in touch with
him
um that think we're shitty that's the
that's that's another
um
beautiful aspect of this whole thing is
his his ability to convince other people
to take his side uh
that aren't you know uh
don't have a they have a bigger you know
a stronger relationship with him
that's their Uncle then
the the uncle outweighs the cousins in a
sense and when when there was a uh
marked split when um
my mom and dad separated and again he
left my mom didn't ask him to leave my
mom didn't you know this I'm sure it
came as a uh quite a shock and a punch
in the stomach to her um uh that he
would move us all down to Roswell
Georgia and then leave uh soon
afterwards right after we were evicted
too we were evicted from our
um
so we lived in a we lived in a um uh
like a motel for a couple weeks and uh
um
and we were we were there wow again I
don't know why the [__] he came went
down there it obviously hadn't been for
some work because why else would you go
to [__]
Roswell Georgia but um
went down there we were in a motel a
couple weeks we got an apartment
um and
um we were there for about three months
I want to say and uh
um
and that's where I turned 10. and uh
and then we got picked up our neighbor
was this guy named Peter George really
cool guy he's the first guy to kind of
get me in a uh
like rock music like he had he got me
into The Who and uh Sergeant Pepper's I
remember that
um
and he usually you'd go we'd the bus
would let us off at the bus stop and
then when all the kids would walk down
to the to the through the apartment
complex uh into their various you know
it wasn't a fancy place you know and
and uh
I don't think my younger sister was in
school yet but um this guy Peter George
our neighbor
um
who drove up after we were uh let off by
the bus and he was going to give us a
ride down to the apartment which is a a
two and a half minute ride tops just
because of speed bumps you know and uh
and the whole reason was to kind of
soften the blow of what we were about to
see
um that's why they my mom sent him up
there
um and
we come down there and they're literally
uh I was very filmic in a sense as we're
approaching they these guys they had
locked uh some of the
uh doors to
um to
I guess I guess uh uh take some of the
things that we add to to because we
hadn't paid rent uh my mom found out you
know like an hour prior to that that my
dad had been lying about paying rent and
we had it had been months and they you
know so they took our a bunch of our
[__] and just put it uh with uh I
wouldn't say lovingly uh on the you know
front area where where you know they're
like those apartment buildings where you
have like four units and a thing or six
unit whatever and uh and just tossing it
on the the concrete and the
um and
you know I had a ham radio uh remember I
had a ham radio that I hadn't really
used but I love the idea of it you know
and this this uh I didn't I wasn't old
enough to really get it but you'd see it
in movies where people and I and I think
my uncle
um might have given it to me somehow I
had this ham radio uh that was gone they
took that they're gonna sell it and they
took that [__] yeah yeah and they had
things that they didn't care about this
was a [__] pile to them even though
these are your things and this is we
might be able to get some money out of
this and they locked some of the the you
know the like uh storage door whatever
you know and uh and you know and we
didn't have a whole lot uh but they
there was stuff you know bedding clothes
it's just on that's literally on the
ground and uh um and then you know we
got split up because uh and we had some
really really super cool
neighbors who were very sympathetic and
they said well you know Wendy and Julie
can sleep with us and uh you know stay
at our house and David can stay here and
you guys can stay you know so we did
have places to go we weren't like uh
sleeping on the street as work because
people kind of came together remember
really well a girl who uh was relatively
new like probably had been in the
complex for less than a month starting a
collection and going around uh and
getting like a coffee uh uh can and um
you know it's like a dollar and 76 cents
or something like going to the kids and
going to people that's nice it's really
nice really sweet have you ever just
been too damn High well we've all been
there and with today's weed finding your
perfect dose can be a dangerous game
that grass is Reviving the pleasure of
the Casual toke so you can chill out
without the stress dad grass is legal
organic smokable hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind they're 100
organic pre-rolled joints which are my
favorite and flower are very low in THC
and high in CBD so you can enjoy the
effects of CBD while keeping a clear
head not looking to toke that grass also
offers the finest tinctures and gummies
on the market all the Mellow goodness no
smoke required all dagrass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the U.S whether you're looking for a new
Buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favor at that grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now dagrass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
honeydew go to
dadgrass.com honeydew for 20 off your
first order that's dadgrass.com honeydew
try it free for 30 days is enough time
to try and completely forget about a
subscription or a service before you
know it you're paying for a subscription
you don't use every single month with
rocket money you can change that with a
few quick Taps rocket money formerly
known as true bill is a personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about like
that streaming service you bought to
watch just one show on or that free
trial that you never even used rocket
money will quickly and easily identify
your subscriptions for you so you can
stop paying for the ones you don't want
simply find a subscription you don't
want and press cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you no more long hold
times with customer service or emailing
back and forth over 3 million people
have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 a year I'm
going to tell you right now as a person
who just spent the month in the hospital
I signed up for every subscription and I
went back and I had no idea that I was
on Discovery plus Showtime Apple TV
YouTube TV HBO did all of them and I had
to go in and be like I don't use this I
don't use this I don't use this boom
rocket money took care of all of it
y'all stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com honeydew that's
rocketmoney.com honeydew rocketmoney.com
honeydew nah let's get back to the do
um
but that uh
boy Ryan I'm I ca I rambled down these
roadside I can't remember the original
question 20 minutes ago you cut them out
of your life at 19 I said yes so you're
about to come up on a 40th anniversary
of not talking to your father yeah
there's going to be a celebration
um
uh we're gonna go to
the play the Wolfgang Puck on uh on uh
Main Street there in Santa Monica I
rented the place out and it's just gonna
be me and my dad it's gonna be weird
it's gonna be weird but uh what talk to
me about look because my father died at
16. so this is in in a in a sense it's a
death for you holy [__] so he had you
when he was 15. and then died
immediately
um
but in a sense when you cut this man off
this is a death to you and what is that
like knowing that you or a 19 year old
man now young man and you don't have a
dad grow going forward well I didn't
really have a dad I hear what that's the
thing I mean he really wasn't there I he
uh
he he so he did this great uh it's just
so classic my dad uh did this thing
where we were so I went out there to
live with him
um and
he clearly hadn't thought it through and
um
I had no money had no job uh and
and there were all these you know fun
little anecdotal things we had uh we had
chocolate he knew a guy who filled uh
vending machines named this guy named
tacky Taki tacky uh Polynesian Guy and
um
um is that politically correct or is
that Polynesian yeah I think so here we
go I want to say he was Hawaiian
but there's no Polynesia is it I don't
know I just know from like Disney films
Islands Islands an island yeah but I
don't know if he was he might have been
Samoan or uh I don't know I'm uh that's
um forgive me the internet again but uh
um
he's described to me as Polynesian but
that might be that might not be right
anymore but uh anyway so this guy uh
gave
uh my dad we were living in this this
I'll never forget either it was uh I've
never seen this anywhere except uh
Phoenix it was um
these it was it was clearly a motel that
was bigger like
um let's say uh 24 units right 12 two
just two floors 12 across 12 on the
bottom kind of angled a little bit maybe
um and then and then there was like a
little uh shitty uh kidney shaped pool
teeny tiny
um that didn't have any water in it and
a faded shuffleboard thing next to it
and the the apartment the the motel had
been divided into three
things that not not physically divided
but just like um there'd be like a a you
know a different color for like these
these six would have a different color
than the Middlesex had different colors
than the other six and um
and they were called like Geronimo
courts and Sitting Bull Lane
no seriously it was all like Indian
themed uh you know and uh
and
it was just this uh
motel that had been I don't know
somebody purchased it and divided it
into three and uh so we were living in a
motel room and also I was uh a super
skinny kid uh I was I was pretty skinny
until you know maybe I was 40 or
something but um uh
and I just you know was one of those I
was a light kid you know I didn't have a
lot of meat on me and uh man my dad was
uh I don't know he's like six foot one
or something like that and um
uh and we slept there was no you know
that we slept in the bed together and
it was bad that he had slept in so he
was kind of in the middle and it there
was like you know
of quite a concave uh like a dip and
then I would and I couldn't sleep in the
bed I couldn't sleep because I would
roll right into him if I just moved for
an end and uh uh so I ended up having to
sleep on the couch and which was fine it
wasn't a big deal it was a you know
again I wasn't
you know tall or wide
um but uh and he had no job and we were
basically in this motel and uh and
it was a little trivia so
the woman's the the landlords uh wife
um
I've uh
her name was Ms santiso and uh she was
one of these very very much like the um
uh
I'm based on their name what's the the
um she's awesome in uh White Lotus she's
the only one who's on Jennifer Coolidge
Jennifer Coolidge very much a Jennifer
Coolidge type character with
um you know bottle blonde kind of
beehivey type big hair mumus uh drinking
always drinking always always drinking
and
um
it wasn't until later I realized my dad
was [__] her and he would send me to
the I think the Safeway I want to say
the Safeway uh it was about a mile down
the road
with a note to get cigarettes uh yeah so
I had permission to get cigarettes uh
for real yeah yeah that is awful the
only reason he did it was to not pay
rent
that's and then we left listen to this
okay it gets it gets better it gets
better so
so uh when we so all right uh so when we
left
um he
prior to leaving he spent a couple of
days convincing me that I was really sad
I wasn't happy there and that I really
wanted to go back
to I miss my family I miss my mom my
sisters and I and I should also say that
my
my childhood in Georgia was pretty
miserable until I was
um
until I was 17.
uh but really uh and I was a pretty
happy kid up until we moved down there
and uh pretty much from
I'd say fifth grade through fifth fifth
through 9th was just
like really really bad really miserable
and he had convinced me
that I wanted to go back there and uh
and I it at first I didn't I I you know
things weren't great certainly in
retrospect as I tell this but
you know in the moment I'm still hanging
with my dad it's my dad this is great I
haven't seen him in years this is so
cool and
I get to play Pinball at the you know
and uh um and you know who needs food
you don't need that much food you know
you just need a little bit of food and
then I you know it's it's it's okay and
uh
and
so he had convinced me that uh we should
go back
and
I was like yeah sure you know we're
gonna uh we're gonna go back so
he gets a drive away truck a pickup
truck corrugated metal back uh in the
back no nothing no bedding or anything
like that and
he I don't remember how he told me or
what he said I should say
to so that we it was going to be a
surprise and um and nobody could know or
something but we had to load up our the
pickup truck at a certain time it had to
be like 10 in the morning
and we couldn't make any noise and uh
and
I kind of knew in the back of my head
just you know
putting all the stuff together what was
happening but I didn't really allow
myself to realize it
but we were clearly skipping out again
he had not paid any rent zero and the
guy had just whatever his wife had done
to convince him to let us stay an extra
week or month or whatever it was and
that kept
you know one week became two became four
became six the guy was like no or you
know he's out of here
um
and so we quietly very quickly loaded up
and there was nothing there was I mean I
came out there I had uh I had gotten a
uh guitar and I had a uh I think it's
the only kind of big thing that I
had I don't even know where I got the
guitar uh that I brought out there with
me and I didn't even know how to play
guitar and um and you know whatever
suitcase would close and stuff and
I also's for part of the story uh in a
minute I had a jade Star of David Noah
Jade uh uh hi
uh necklace that I'd gotten uh my bar
mitzvah and
so we load up the pickup truck and uh
and then you know we like peel out of
there get out of there we stop at a pawn
shop he grabs the guitar yes yes yes
yeah and then he goes uh he goes
um and he and he told me
uh we you know I need we need I don't
have the money or whatever it was he
told me basically he didn't he wasn't
that shitty where he just took it pawned
it and with no explanation he said we
need this for the gas money to get us to
Georgia you know I calculated it it's a
long thing and then he asked for my
necklace and I gave it to him and uh
and some there were a handful of other
things and he was like you know I'm
gonna
I don't know what he happened like you
know my golf clubs I'm gonna pawn my
golf club whatever this stuff was
um
and
he pawned it they got money this is on
our way out uh and and then we took off
for for Georgia and I uh we we got back
with a nickel
this sounds like I'm making this [__] up
but we literally had a nickel we would
have posted into Georgia with a nickel
yeah and we and also there's this I
forgot about this part so part of the
secret right is don't tell your mom
it'll be a surprise wouldn't it be so
cool when you show up don't tell them
we're coming out and that was not about
me that was about him
that was about don't tell your mom I
didn't that one I didn't figure out
until later
um but the whole thing was like it's a
secret we're gonna surprise your mom and
your sisters are gonna be so happy that
you're home oh my God David's gonna be
great the whole thing was because he he
had run out of options clearly had made
more enemies than friends out there and
owed a bunch of money and
was and his idea which he ended up doing
was he crashed on our couch for I don't
know how long I'll have to ask my mom
but like you know a month until he
somehow
bullshitted his way into another
situation
um but we were all
so thrilled to have her dad back in
Atlanta you know that my mom had to bite
her tongue and uh
you know and he came in and he he's
really good at
reading the room you know and going and
just
Charming you know like hey people he did
not give a [__] about never called would
forget birthdays and all of a sudden
he's backing going Julie Wendy give me a
hug you know I've missed you so much I'm
gonna stay here and I'm gonna you know
and my mom's an adult she's suss the
whole thing out and I I probably was uh
you know in denial about a lot of it and
I don't think Wendy and Julie had any
clue
um and
and yeah then he was then he was in
Atlanta until he wasn't again
do you remember
he was
living with your mom is he moves in an
apartment
there was no he was on the couch this is
this is not a house this is an apartment
there's a
um
and
eventually he got a place downtown
um and he was a waiter
at a place and then he became
he was a waiter for a for a while and he
and he was uh lived with another uh
waiter
um
then he ended up
doing food and beverage service stuff
for a hotel one of the hotels downtown
and
and then he moved to Florida when I was
gosh I don't know like so he was there
for a couple years like three years I
want to say no I I asked everybody to
send stuff that they want to talk and
there's so much you're going to have to
come back and do another episode because
here's what I want to ask you now now
you're a dad yes okay but you I was also
I was a older dad I didn't have a I mean
my daughter was
when she was born I was 41. she's eight
now and your daughter's how old she
literally just turned six last week six
so you 52 you were roughly when you had
a baby um
does
and I asked this to especially people
that were like does the fact that your
father was the way he was does it scare
the [__] out of you that you could have
that in you or you don't even have to
finish you don't have to flip and you
don't have to finish the question it was
uh
it was at the Forefront of decision
making it was a a fear that I had way
before I even had a kid I knew I wanted
to have a family
um but it was something I thought about
even before I met my wife was is this a
genetic thing is this a thing in the
brain that I'm not I can look at it
right now logically with uh uh either
dispassionate or emotionally with
passion and go this is terrible this is
I want I want I'm gonna I'm gonna take
care of my kids I'm gonna be responsible
dad especially because of what I went
through absolutely but is there a switch
that this thing happens that allows you
to turn all that off justify
um you know irresponsible selfish
behavior
um uh not that I demonstrated that
before but
it that was like uh you know like
a genetic thing like oh maybe I have
taste sacks maybe something's in there I
don't know how the [__] do I know and uh
and I it was something that was with me
for a long time and as my wife and I
discussed you know having a family like
let's let's have some kids and
um
it was always it's something I I brought
up to her too of course but uh and I
didn't think it was going to be the case
but I but how would you know and then if
it happened there's this thing that
allows you to justify that you know
somehow and um I was always uh
really afraid of that
um
and
because here's the thing and you know I
say this as if it couldn't happen but
I'm saying this to you right now in this
with the uh logic and and a heart that
says there's no way I mean I I'm I
haven't demonstrated that all I've done
the exact opposite
um uh almost to a to a you know
egregious degree and uh
um but who knows maybe it happens maybe
I find myself at a bar sometime going
like yeah because here's what I imagine
my dad
doing
is
not that he sat down with a pen and
paper went oh here's a pro list of you
know being a good dad and here's a con
list you know let's weigh out the pros
and cons I just think he's the kind of
person
that didn't even
take that into account or or that wasn't
part of his mindset I think he just
kind of woke up one day and the nagging
feeling that was there he had to address
which was
yeah I thought I'd be into it but I'm
kind of not so I'm gonna take off yeah
I'm out guys and and um
which is what he did he's like I need to
you know whatever [__] he told my
mom you know I need to get my head
together in order to you know
uh
be a better person and whatever uh but
that was clearly not his he never
intended to at all he was never coming
back when he left even though he
kind of intimated that you know this is
for the best for me and I'll you know
get my [__] together and you know
whatever I'll be the greatest dad and
husband ever
that it was just an excuse to get
they'll get far far away and uh
um
and so you know I just it's that fear
that like am I gonna go you know what
I'm not into being married or being a
dad I don't like this because I just
made a mistake
whoopsie doodle you know and uh
and so yes I I thought about that uh
quite a bit especially as as my daughter
was
uh coming to uh fruition and uh and then
I'm with you on this I don't uh
parenting's a long game and I don't ever
see me not talking to my daughter or
anything but what if there's a boyfriend
and I know he's not a good dude and I'm
like look I just I'm not crazy about
that guy and that's enough for her to
say that I'm not talking to you or
whatever then you know you got who knows
you want to figure out how to work that
out right yeah down the line but do you
find yourself here's my next question is
do you also find yourself over
correcting because of that fear
yes and I I I
have learned uh
like if we had another kid I would not
uh
go about it the same way and I know uh
parents have that uh relationship with
you know uh first second third first
fourth yes of course and you know you
learn uh I know that that's as old as
time but I heard this saying the other
day that you raise your kids so you can
spoil your grandkids because if you
spoil your kids you're going to be
raising your grandkids and I was like Ah
that's [__] that's a good one way
powerful but so then I worry because I
was the same way my mom was this kid is
spoiled abusive and left the [__]
family so I also was like [__] is that a
gene in me I had the same fear that's
why I asked and then there are times
where I do find myself
overdoing and I'm like you got two of
them people say what is what does your
daughter want for I'm like my daughter
doesn't need a thing my daughter
genuinely like I know we're all doing a
good job as parents because there's not
a thing my dog she wants things but
there's nothing she needs we have an
abundance and I always teach her too
like if you want new stuff then we
donate old stuff to kids who are not
like you there are kids out there I tell
her that don't even have parents and she
that blows their mind like what I'm like
yeah that happens so let's let's help
other kids too well yeah I I can't say
that I've been wildly successful at that
again she just turned six so maybe
that'll hopefully come in the next few
years but I that's been a literally that
exact conversation
um numerous times and uh but she also
goes to we're in Brooklyn and she goes
to public school so there are uh kids
that are not even
remotely
as well off
um or you know like they're kids who
you know have uh eat breakfast at school
because they that's part of that's a
program
um
and uh the parents can't necessarily
afford uh and they've got to work longer
hours so they can't even be there you
know they're working 13 hours a day yeah
it was a free lunch yeah
I had to show the ticket in front of
everybody like oh lose it we felt like a
loser for that I gotta say I a lot of uh
a lot of the
I think it wasn't until later
that there were affluent kids in the
schools I went to at least in Georgia
um uh
so it wasn't that uncommon the the free
lunch
um and free breakfast but uh
um
but yeah this kid is uh I mean maybe
spoiled I don't know we'll have a better
idea fairly shortly and we won't really
know until she's you know 16 17 18 you
know we'll see but you said if you had
another kid you would do it differently
yes I I
felt such guilt uh about not being there
for her
constantly which is absurd and uh
um
if I went to
you know like if uh
daycare was something you know if I was
like oh can you stay an extra hour or
whatever and I go to the pub uh and have
a beer have a pint or two
I think like I'm I'm not there with her
when I should be and and uh
um and I I did something really again in
hindsight being 2020 uh I went on a
tour uh and she was with me you see my
wife I had a tour bus this is a big big
tour
and uh I can't tour this way anymore
because she's in school now but
um so now I kind of you know do like
four or five dates come back for you
know the weekdays and then go out for
the weekends but um uh but before she
was in school like I you know I'd have
like a four month long tour and for most
of that we had a pack and play installed
in the room in the back and
um it was my wife my my wife is uh
an author and had put a book out in the
last two tours I did simultaneously uh
had a book release so she would go and
do bookstores
um and I would go do a show and then oh
yeah yeah it was great and and uh our
daughter would be in the uh with us and
and
um
and when I went to Europe uh I always do
a European leg and
and uh you know normally I'd be if I'm
doing Europe I'm there for minimum three
weeks giving myself some breaks enjoying
myself going ah got a free day in
Antwerp you know whatever
um uh although people are kind of
douchey and Antwerp
I know they're not they're not that
Pleasant
um
anyway uh so I would I you know normally
and my wife would uh be with me for a
chunk and and uh you know but I really
enjoy being in in Europe and uh and
so the last tour I did I stupidly shaved
off
every possible moment so that I wouldn't
miss an hour with my daughter God forbid
who at this point is like what three you
know I mean they're not even awesome yet
and uh you're right they're not even
right they're not so uh
so I go I literally
did the itinerary where I'm working
every single night and I'm in Dublin and
then I'm in you know uh leads and then
I'm in uh you know whatever uh uh Oslo
and then I'm in Stockholm and I'm just
not I just did I only give myself a
couple extra days in London and uh
and I flew in day of show for to
Manchester was my first show and I was
[__] Bonkers I mean jet lag and
trying to uh remember my stuff I had my
notes on a table and I was telling them
like guys I'm in I'm I feel like I've
I'm I'm on drugs but I'm also being
waterboarded but I'm also covered in you
know gummy bear like it was it and they
were great the audience is very
forgiving and it wasn't that bad but man
I was my brain was scrambling to [__]
do it and I've been up for I was just a
zombie went all the way did a show my
the last show I did in Europe was in
Amsterdam
the next morning it got on a uh I had to
make a connection
uh when Amsterdam
to Manchester back to New York uh also I
could only be gone for whatever 12 13
days tops no no you know just traveling
everything you know and um doing the
show in Amsterdam and then getting up at
4 30 in the morning to get to the
airport to get to Manchester to get to
New York I walk home
I got my suitcase and she's on the couch
the TV her her back is to me on the
couch watching cartoon
and
you know I come in with my bags and uh
ammo I was like guess who so a very
special somebody who misses you whatever
and I'm I'm sorry if you're only
listening this but imagine the back of
my head is to you and like look who it
is and this is what my daughter is
officially is what my daughter cartoons
over here she goes like that she goes
you have no kid you have no [__] idea
what I just went through
not even a hello not even a high Daddy
not even hello
yes acknowledgment a smile
oh [__] I will never [__] do that
again so good dude so stupid that's
always
um all right also that's our trauma
right we're I want to make sure I get I
was the same way like I want every
moment I want all this so you had
emailed into about your anxiety where
does your anxiety come from what do you
have anxiety about I I don't know where
it comes from and I I I've had it since
I was a kid I didn't know it was anxiety
until much much later I was like oh I
never thought I had anxiety and I was
like wait that's what this feeling I
have is yeah and it it totally makes
sense but I I had uh a couple little
episodes uh and I I do mean little they
were minor in compared to other
people's uh experiences but I had uh two
little freakouts or I you know torch it
up and I put my hand through a window
and I cut my you know I did all this
stuff and I
um
you know freaked out my my mom and my
family of course and I had two of those
well one when I was like
oh gosh uh
you know probably let's say 12 13 and
then another a little later when I was
about 16 where I you know just snapped
and I you know
um never saw it as anxiety I always
thought it was just uh
depression in the simplistic umbrella
term uh because I was depressed and um
and things were depressing so I thought
that's what it was and then
uh
uh many many many years later uh ended
up going to a therapist getting talked
into it I didn't want to do it I kind of
went in reluctantly uh ignorantly I look
back on that as just one of the dumbest
ignorant the prideful stupid I mean so
even still when I'm in therapy the
therapist tell me that we're among it's
not many men that go yeah you know it's
a small percentage unfortunately and I'm
not like that it wasn't like a
machismo thing it was more like uh
I mean I'll tell you what it was it was
and this is probably true for most
people it was really going
you know uh acknowledging my weakness
and a thing that I I always thought I
can handle this I can I'm I can deal
with this it's fine and I was raised I
was you know when my dad left when I was
uh you know when I was 10 my my mom I
remember my mom saying we were driving
the car she's like well it's you know
you're gonna have to be the man of the
family now and I didn't want I was just
turned 10. a little early but
um and uh um I mean listen no offense
but the bar is set low man you didn't
have to do too much dude
you didn't
even like I can leave too whatever I
want oh so I don't have to contribute a
thing okay I can emotionally manipulate
you all right great damn that's a lot
man
oh if I had only had the foresight
uh
yeah so I started seeing this therapist
it was great uh I mean just a lifesaver
amazing amazing lady and and she said I
think you need to see a psychiatrist
because I think we should talk about
some medication and
um and she's like here's this guy that I
work with that he's great
and then when I went to this new guy who
was um
it's so funny I don't know if you've had
this experience but I
so the therapist I went to was very
warm and uh um
you know empathetic and as I as a
therapist should be I suppose and uh but
the psychiatrist you know who's the one
with the different uh different training
different set of degrees who's you see a
psychiatrist because they can prescribe
you medication and that's why she sent
me to him and the therapist is trained
to you know help you work out your come
to understandings work out your
your issues and uh and they this guy was
like you know scientist uh uh and they
could not have been he was just yes I
mean and just writing and just nothing
no no warp nothing here here's a
prescription
um I'm not knocking it I'm just saying
they're two wildly different things but
so I went and saw him for a little while
um and he
gave me this prescription and he's the
one who said
all right this is for anxiety you have
anxiety and I was like well I don't
think I have anxiety I don't think
that's the issue uh he's like no it's
exactly you have anxiety that's what
this is going to help treat and it was a
real eye-opening experience because
again he wasn't sugarcoating anything
he's just as a psychiatrist saying
clinically this is what you have and
depression can come under you know can
be a manifest itself in many different
ways and
and it wasn't until like that was late
in life I was like oh and then of course
everything made sense everything yes uh
the way that I am
uh when uh my wife and I uh before I met
her I had a house a tiny little house
built in uh Upstate in the woods in New
York and um
and then the way once we got together
and
um
and when we'd go up there for you know
six days two weeks three weeks whatever
uh and then when we were leaving I was I
just turned into an [__] and it was
like not an [__] like mean or
anything but just like okay unpleasant
to be with like okay we got to be out
here I don't want to hit traffic and
this has to look like this and and those
aren't things that I I'm not like that
I'm not uh anal like that I'm not a neat
freak I'm not uh
um but if things aren't kind of this way
and they need to be this way and and it
started getting worse and worse after
having
because the thing is I had gone up my
medication because I told my wife uh
when we were going to get married I was
like you know I've been on this stuff as
she knew and I think you should
know who I am without it you know uh I
think that's just fair you know it's not
Jekyll and Hyde thing they're just
differences it takes the edge off it
does these things and
um and so I went off of the medication
which I wanted to do anyway
um
and then
it was manageable uh and then
once my daughter started going to school
uh which is relatively recently uh
it got bad again and it's bad to the
point where I mean I'm
gonna see another psychiatrist and I'm
gonna get the meds back because I'm
yeah what are you struggling with uh
just I'm I'm just unpleasant I'm gonna
I'm like
and not as a roommate or a husband or a
partner but as a dad where it like
getting her to school and I could hear
it and I tell and I saved my head like
chill out it's okay you can be three
minutes late it's okay if she doesn't
have her shoes on at 8 12 you know we're
gonna be fine and I'm saying this to
myself and I'm still like
that's not what we do it no okay well
and I'm acting in wait you're like I'm
putting guilt on her and all this [__]
and it's like [__] chill we can't be
late though that's the thing at this
school if you're a minute late they
write that [__] down they call you and
tell you like hey I'm like [__] so now
we you know what they're like you're
giving me anything right right right
right I would
okay I would say to you what I would say
to me is like who cares if the school
calls you because you're two minutes
late [__] you we're two minutes late
we're in L.A I've got a kid there are a
million mitigating and yes I will try to
do better but I'm not gonna take that
out on my kid I'm not gonna yell at a
five-year-old you know uh we'll figure
out how your skirt goes on you put it on
the wrong way yeah right and now that's
why it's itchy now take I mean that is
not cool I don't want to do that and I
can and again it just it's gotten worse
as once he got to school started and uh
and it really I knew that I'm like okay
I gotta I gotta take care of this [__]
because we were playing a video game so
there's this I recommend this to uh
parents if you if you're looking for a
game
um
there's I just looked up e you know an
e-rated game to play with my daughter
and uh there's a game called rainbow
Billy I don't know the rest of it
rainbow Billy in the world of
imagination or something like that it's
really good it teaches your kids I
didn't know that I just saw that it was
you know e for everybody and it's just
very cartoony thing and you're trying to
bring color back to the world of
imagination all right it seems
simplistic enough but um uh anyway she's
playing this game that's designed for
children little children and
and I'm like sitting next to her and
this is also part of like daddy daughter
time you know we it's you know my wife
doesn't play with her nobody else plays
I mean we play and we have a good time
but I'll find myself talking to a five
well she's six now but five-year-old
going like no okay you're gonna fall off
the thing all right well you just fell
off
okay well now we have to start over like
what is wrong with me
it's a kid I'm sucking the job okay I'm
sucking the joy out of this experience
because of my [__] dumb useless you
know what else sucks too is our parents
were never part of a video game
generation so they could never come up
and sit and do that you have played
you're like God damn it I told you
joking well and oh like it's not like
Marla can you just give me give me the
controller can I take can I can I just
get us to the gonna get us the magic
mushroom because we can't jump we can't
jump to the other platform where the
coins are unless we have a map okay well
then that's fine you do it yourself then
you know just shitty awful
not not a good way to be as a kid and I
and I know it and I know it and I tell
myself and I try to do better but I I'm
telling you it's just uh it's really
come back in a in a noticeable way I
could always kind of you know manage it
and also I know what I'm doing and I'd
say you know for before Marlo was born
I'd say to my wife like I'm sorry okay
you're right all right I you didn't say
anything but I know you're right
whatever you think it is right I gotta
okay let's we're gonna be okay it's fine
um and uh
and then you know
again what's once she once
when she got into school it just really
came roaring back and I gotta deal with
it so I'm gonna have to deal with it
listen this has been an awesome episode
I know there was other things I think
the internet will be the judge of that
they win they will but I want to say
this look I was so stoked to hear you
wanted to be on here and have you on I'm
a huge [__] fan I mean I also love
all of your choices you've had such a
range I mean obviously I'm you go all
the way back to Mr show but Tobias is a
[__] yeah I got lucky on that one man
still one of my faves and then Kirsten
reminded me I think she said it was uh
scary movie two you're in a wheelchair
yeah yeah yeah but there's so many
[__] things and I love you and I love
your choices and I really appreciate you
coming on and doing this show Absolutely
my pleasure is [__] awesome you know
we were having this conversation before
we started rolling about the how
you know the positive things about
podcasts and and how uh and this is a
great example of you know came out here
I want to promote the tour uh you know
here's a there's a bunch of Stuffy and
there's there's Everything's changed and
it's uh and these are literally the most
enjoyable way
to do that thing that you have to do
yeah
um as opposed to a junk it or The
Tonight Show or the serious radio tours
or or the
um you know
20 conversations with local newspapers
for 12 minutes where they're asking the
same questions this we had a real
conversation I got to know you your
audience gets to know me uh you know and
if we're talking about real things and
it was a pleasure thank you no thank you
um I you know the other thing too about
podcasting that I love is they're
getting to know David Cross versus again
I'll go back to bias you know they come
to see you because they love that
character people that love podcasting
and listen to podcasts come out to see
you because they love David Cross when
you get your show going they're really
good to know you every week you know
what I mean they really know you who you
are
um so let's get less walkouts that way
yeah
you know I don't know what a show would
be like if I didn't have somebody
walking out going what the [__]
what in the
um something I ask every guest first
time here after everything we've talked
about now advice you would give to your
16 year old self
uh
uh 16 was a particularly bad year it
seems to be that for a lot of people but
it seems to be the right around history
yeah I know I'm saying that like I'm
some sort of unicorn that only I feel
like my experience
um
I would I would I would I mean
I'm gonna I'm gonna think about the
answer to that question knowing that I'm
talking to
the kind of person I'm talking to who
might not be receptive to
um
and probably wouldn't be receptive to a
58 year old person saying hey here's
what you need to do kid
um
so I would say
you know I guess probably I was just
starting to become a little bit more
understanding about patience and the
long game so I try to appeal to that and
say you know uh
assuming in this crazy scenario that the
person doesn't know that I'm really the
58 year old version of himself because
because otherwise I would blow his mind
and I wouldn't believe it I just
wouldn't believe it why would I
um so it's just a random guy happens to
look like the Aged version of the 16
year old
I'll go look you're gonna
um
you're gonna make a lot of bad choices
you're gonna uh be you're going to
overcompensate for your
insecurities by drinking a lot and doing
drugs and that's okay it is actually
okay uh just be careful I know you will
be I because I know
um but be careful but
this is easier said than done but be
patient
uh
uh pick your battles
and uh
you will it's your choices are going to
be okay and you're always gonna you just
have to be honest with yourself because
you won't make good choices if you're
not honest with yourself and it's okay
to make bad choices it's okay to make
mistakes B honest with yourself
and that will lead you to getting
through some of the bad choices and also
believe in yourself uh a little less
than you do right now because you're a
bit cocky for my taste you've got
nothing to show for it hey [__]
you've got nothing where's the arrogance
coming from you've got nothing to show
for it you will but you don't right now
that resonates hard
that's great man
um again promote everything one more
time please uh the tour starts on March
2nd uh and it's called the worst daddy
in the world tour it will uh you can
find all the places I'm playing and uh
where to get tickets at my website
officialdavidcross.com there I think
they're about 40 dates right now don't
worry I promise they're gonna be others
we're working on now we're going to do
this in two different legs maybe even
three uh so if it's if your place if
your town isn't up there right now it
probably will be in the future uh and
it'll be start March 2nd
gonna run through October no
thank you again man this has been
absolutely been awesome yeah um as
always ryansickler.com Ryan sickler on
all social media we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign